longmire thrilled fans with its
depiction of life out west
season after season secrets about the
residents of its small town are revealed
in the end all of them come crashing
together creating one majorly compelling
drama
let's catch up with its talented cast
and see what trails they're heading down
now
robert taylor completely embodies the
small town cowboy-like sheriff longmire
his performance is as powerful as it is
nuanced you'd think he grew up alongside
the likes of john wayne and clint
eastwood
fun fact he's not american at all taylor
is actually australian
and should absolutely get an award for
fooling everyone
since starring on longmire taylor has
been busy living life off-screen in
melbourne australia
his instagram is filled with pictures of
him getting beers with friends rooting
on the dodgers and traveling he even
made a trip back to wyoming
if you miss watching the sheriff on
screen you can see taylor as dr heller
in the 2018 film
the meg or as reverend covern in the
down from dover episode of the
delightful dolly parton's heartstrings
anyone associated with dolly while also
living his best life surrounded by
friends and family
is doing it right the will they won't
they relationship between deputy sheriff
vic moretti and walt longmire features
throughout the entire series
and while they decide to live together
their past relationships never allow
them to fully commit to one another
this badass detective is played by the
equally awesome katie sackhoff
moretti is tough layered and intelligent
much like the other characters sachof
portrays
since her time on longmire sackoff has
been continuously working
often in major franchises in the
arrowverse she plays amunet black on the
flash
she also wields the power of her voice
playing various characters on robot
chicken
but she is perhaps best known as boca
tan crees
sachof originally only played her on the
animated star wars the clone wars series
but
dave filoni and jon favreau decided to
bring bokehtan to life in season 2 of
the mandalorian
inviting katie sackhoff along for the
ride
some of us serve a higher purpose if
you're looking for even more of
sackhoff's brilliance look no further
than netflix
she stars as nico breckenridge on the
sci-fi thriller series
another life it's safe to say that this
hard-working woman
and friend of baby yoda is already a
legend
a resident of the cheyenne reservation
owner of the red pony and accused killer
henry standing bear is a longtime friend
of walt longmire
the connection between the two paired
with lou diamond phillips engaging
portrayal
made this character one of the most
prominent pieces of the show
phillips is not new to the hollywood
scene in 1987 he received
rave reviews for his portrayal of
ritchie valens in la bamba
his career continued to thrive with a
tony award nomination for the king and i
and a golden globe nomination for stand
and deliver
since the finale of longmire philip's
success has known no bounds
he's actually a world-class poker player
frequently playing in major tournaments
guess his stoic persona as henry
standing bear comes in handy even beyond
longmire even though he hasn't managed
to win big at the world series of poker
yet you never know how the chips will
fall
while you wait for his epic victory you
can catch him on the fox series prodigal
son as gil
arroyo if cassidy freeman looks familiar
it's because you probably remember her
as tess mercer on the hit show
smallville
after her tenure on the superman drama
ended she stepped into the shoes of
katie longmire
katie or punk as she's affectionately
known as a lawyer sheriff longmire's
daughter
and branch's girlfriend henry's arrest
sends her career in a new direction as a
public defender for members of the
reservation
the series ends with her following her
father's sheriff path
freeman is a woman of many talents she's
in an indie rock band with her brother
called the real decoy
she's also politically and socially
active volunteering her time in support
of jon ossoff during the 2020 election
on screen she's kept busy with roles on
the big screen in 2021's the forever
purge and on the small screen in hbo's
the righteous gemstones
god i have hitched my wagon to a force
for good
and i lucky ladies lucky freeman
absolutely shines in every role she
tackles and will likely continue to do
so
bailey chase is branch connolly an
affluent and ambitious detective
and the on-again off-again boyfriend of
katie longmire
in a tragic turn of events soon after
branch has kicked off the force
he's killed by his own father like his
character chase played football at duke
university on a scholarship
luckily for us he became an actor and
has been working steadily for years
after playing the disgraced deputy he
joined the casts of 24 legacy
twin peaks and swat he also reunited
with his longmire castmate a martinez on
queen of the south
chase's frequently updated instagram is
particularly fun for longmire fans to
peruse
it's filled with adorable pictures of
his family pets travels and
passions take a closer look and you'll
discover his handle is branch lives
a member of the cheyenne reservations
tribal police force officer matthias is
a frequent thorn in longmire's side
it's a bit over the top to cuff him well
you don't have permission operate on the
rest
matthias is a bit of an enigma forcing
the audience to constantly question if
he's working towards good or bad aims
this uncertainty leads to an incredibly
nuanced and dynamic performance from
zhan mclarnon
as a native american actor of lakota
descent mclarnon is part of a small
minority of working indigenous actors
ucla's hollywood diversity report
revealed only 0.5 percent of top film
roles were played by native american
actors as recently as 2019
even though the industry should be more
inclusive across the board mclarnon's
casting as officer matthias is
enormously important and
forward thinking mclarnon's career is
filled with unique and interesting roles
he played handsy dent in the second
season of fargo and the critically
acclaimed role of akita on westworld
in 2021 he'll appear as william lopez on
marvel's hawkeye
mclarnon is breaking barriers for
indigenous actors and is kicking butt
while doing it
a seemingly bumbling addition to the
team deputy archie the ferg ferguson is
just a diamond in the rough
his relationship with longmire is filled
with heart and mutual admiration
when ferguson tries to resign he gets
one of the series most heartbreaking
lines
i know it was a favor
i only got hired because you were
helping out my dad
the strong bond between him and longmire
shines through as longmire refuses the
resignation still seeing potential in
ferguson
thank goodness for that because the show
wouldn't be the same without the ferg
since longmire adam bartley has appeared
on a plethora of great shows
he plays carl brown on ncis los angeles
eric doyle on lucifer and
duke on this is us hopefully he'll soon
play another wonderful series regular
role like deputy ferguson
in the meantime his instagram is filled
with joy including his adorable animals
and reunion photos with his longmire
cast members
perhaps the most disliked character on
longmire business opportunist and
cheyenne tribal committee member jacob
nighthorse
is brilliantly portrayed by a martinez
as with all the multi-layered characters
on this show there is
more to night horse than meets the eye
martinez is able to walk the line of
being beyond despicable and remarkably
engaging creating a standout performance
in longmire
the semi-pro baseball player turned
actor began his career in film
but is best known for his work on soap
operas after rapping on longmire he
found a home again in soap operas
playing eduardo eddie hernandez on nbc's
days of our lives
if his top shelf acting on longmire is
any indication of what he brings to days
of our lives he deserves all the daytime
emmys
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]